[Applause]
my co-pilot today is hilarious always
enthusiastic and a dear friend of our
show who is with us
all week ross matthews i'm back hi
i love the bad headpiece thank you lee
harris put it on me
he adorned me with bats and i thought
could i put them at a donkey angle
you can always do a jaunty angle honey
especially when i'm here yeah exactly
i'm a little jaunty myself so no
straight arrow over here
uh not here either
there's nothing straight about anything
that's going on
but i will tell you there is some
straight up good news are you ready ross
i'm ready you got your whistle i have
yesterday i wanted a whistle when we
talked about sports they gave me this
one listen
oh listen i can't even whistle right
okay ready
sports short sports
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right last night the dodgers did it
and they won the world series they did
it's the first time in 32 years and they
did it just 16 days after the lakers won
the nba championship making it a
double double for the city of l.a
yeah i just want to congratulate the
golden state my
home my birthplace my beloved that's
going through such a hard time
and i'm just so glad you have this
wonderful double double good right
isn't it wonderful it feels like
everything's not
normal and yucky and here's something
fantastic we can all come together
unless you're uh not a fan of the
dodgers but otherwise we can celebrate
i think i think it's just win-win yeah
um okay and our next story is something
that mr matthews found
well take it away well i'll tell you
this so okay i'm obsessed with love i
love love and all my friends are saying
it's impossible to date during covid
right well
uh one writer at refinery29 says no it's
actually
the perfect time to date and here's why
she says number one
since we're all working less if working
at all there's a lot more
stuff to talk about you're not just
talking about your jerk boss you're
talking about like your inner thoughts
your feelings your emotions and number
two
if you're dating like online or facetime
sex
is off the table for the most part and
so you can actually
you can focus on all that other stuff
other other than sex
and i'll tell you something i think that
she's onto something this writer and i
have some experience
i started dating somebody in january
right
and then the world this this is breaking
news the world shut down and then we've
managed to keep it like going uh-huh on
facetime
talking every day he lives in new york
i'm in l.a
and i think it's the key it's why it's
worked because we've had to like
just have actual conversations and you
know in the first couple months of
dating
there's not a whole lot of talking going
on it's true usually it can give you
sort of a false sense because you're so
into the other stuff which there's
nothing wrong with that
but you know getting to know someone and
knowing who you're really going to be
dealing with
is kind of nice to know up front so
i think it is a win-win as well
and i have to say there is something
about the fourth quarter of 2020
i feel like romance is in the air this
is like the first time
in five years my libido is like oh
she waking up i think it's waking up i
got a fun flirty text the other day tell
me
everything and i was like oh my gosh
i'm enjoying this exchange really so
okay have you been like in a hibernation
for a minute
about five years okay that's a lot
that's a minute yeah okay
i haven't you know i just haven't been
serious you know i was married for
four years and we were together for a
while it's been about a decade
you know since it's been me and my kids
and their dad and i just
haven't found the time or room so i feel
optimistic about
this time and i do think that with
everything being so upside down and
there's so much to fix and we need to be
aware of the problem so that we can fix
them
but these little side things are popping
up
underneath from the ground and blooming
in new areas
yes and that is i think what's happening
with dating i think so i think we're all
insisting on something good coming out
of 2020 and if it's a flirty text
uh let's bring another one and another
one on another one as soon as i have
more news i'm giving it right to you
yeah i'll help you write the text back
by the way speaking of cookie romance
okay
guess what time it is it's time for a
bachelorette watch
[Applause]
okay so that villa full of drama
yeah now i'm a first-timer yeah so i
i love pop culture but i never watched
the bachelor or bachelorette before
because it was the one thing that made
me feel good about my life choices
yeah that i wasn't watching that show
like we're above it we're too like
highfalutin
totally above it turns out i'm totally
not
i am so into this i watched just for you
because i know we want to talk about it
and now i
it you know like in the shower in the
mornings when you think about your own
life
yeah this morning i thought about claire
and dale right
okay what is the deal because
they had margaret cho on last night and
she hosted
a roast she hosted a roasted and
all the guys got like like ripped on
dale
uh-huh well they ripped on dale for a
reason because she
it's like she's not playing the rules of
the game she has like
honed in on dale and it's if she were
bowling she'd just be knocking down the
same pin and all the other pins would be
like can i play
good metaphor thank you and i think it's
kind of unfair to all these other men
well they're not happy about it in fact
we have a clip take a look
oh this is good it appeared to me that
like she took some stuff personally
is she a little perturbed that we made
fun of
her man right now i really don't think i
can sit there and go
you dished on my fiance so hard like
like i can't be doing that
you know like it doesn't feel right it's
like i've never been in
on the game of the bachelorette um she
said
fiance so she did when she left she said
i can't believe they did that with me
and my fiance
fiance one you've known him for three
and a half days you've
made out four times are you engaged
please
but then but then look at dale and it
kind of starts making sense
right well also in the um
end of the show there was a promo
bringing tasha
back around who is stunning and i just
get a sense from watching the promo of
what the series is going to be for the
year that claire is not sticking around
something big is going off the track
there's a revolt
coming right and then tasha's going to
come in out of that pool
dripping wet to save the day and i'm
going to be there
watching every minute of it well we're
going to both be there together all
right we're going to go to commercial
wait wait no you're not going
i have one more thing for you drew will
you accept this rose
only if you'll accept my resume
social distance rosing by the way
this is two 20 20 fourth quarter
things blooming looming where they were
desert dry before
oh grow you got to show me that text
[Laughter]
i was looking at like an arid desert
like i had a whole landscape but yeah
you know what bats let's face it thank
you ross
you